son d'éventuels crimes dont commis en
ukraine c'est donc celle que je pose la
cour pénale internationale c'est aussi
la question que s'est posée la rédaction
des observateurs bonjour thomas et d'où
vous êtes de 7,7 rédaction dont des
observateurs et vous vous êtes penché
sur la question des bombes à sous
munitions utilisées ou pas en ukraine où
vous allez nous dire d'abord est ce que
pour nous expliquer ce que sont ces
armes bien alors tout simplement nous
allons nous concentrer sur les roquettes
à sous munitions on peut le voir à
l'écran on va le voir juste ici c'est un
modèle de fabrication russe 9ème 55 cas
c'est précis ce n'est pas une vraie
roquettes 1 c'est un dessin mais ça nous
permet de comprendre comment tout ça
cela comment tout ça fonctionne dans la
partie arrière il ya le moteur avec le
carburant qui permet de propulser les
roquettes et puis à l'avant se trouve à
un container où l'on retrouve à
l'intérieur de nombreuses petites bombes
lorsque la roquette arrive sur sa cible
le conteneur s'ouvre pour larguer donc
ces petites bombes des dizaines de
bombes sur la cible tandis que l'arrière
de la roquette le moteur continue sa
route et le but c'est de maximiser les
dégâts de faire l'exact us de dégâts
possibles autour c'est ça exactement ces
requêtes peuvent être tirés depuis ce
véhicule on le voit à l'écran un modèle
smertch de fabrication russe qui peut en
tirer environ une dizaine par salves aux
observateurs nous sommes donc focalisés
sur le cas de kharkiv on en parlait tout
à l'heure à l'est du pays environ 30 km
de la frontière russe c'est la deuxième
ville la plus peuplée du crin d'ukraine
pardon ce lundi 28 février lundi dernier
nous avons analysé une frappe qui a eu
lieu sur un entrepôt en plein milieu
d'habitations civiles sur la carte qui
va arriver à l'écran on peut voir la
zone qui a été visée là où nous avons
géolocaliser les vidéos les frappes et
les bouts de roquettes qui ont continué
leur course ici on peut voir la vidéo
c'est un frappe d'accord sur l'entrepôt
on peut voir et entendre sur l'image de
multiples explosions et maintenant on va
voir à l'écran l'un des boues des
requêtes que nous avons géolocaliser une
centaine de mètres plus loin
hum voilà on peut le voir juste ici donc
c'est le bouddha roquettes juste après
qu'il eut la frappe qu'on retrouve juste
après
est ce qu'on s'est concrètement thomas
qui est l'auteur de cette frappe qui a
tiré sur cet entrepôt de kharkiv le 28
février et bien justement après avoir
géolocaliser la vidéo de la frappe et
puis la vidéo du bout de requêtes on
peut avoir une idée nous avons que
l'arrière de la requête que nous avons
vu donc dans la rue donc toujours plus
loin que l'endroit qui est visé par ce
qu'elle continue sa course donc nous
avons tracé une droite qui part du lieu
où est tombée la requête en passant par
l'endroit qui était visé pour tenter de
retrouver l'origine du point de tir un
chercheur de l'atlantic council et qui
s'appelle michael sheldon a lui aussi
tracer cette grotte et puis une autre
dans une autre attaque qui a eu lieu
juste à côté on peut le voir ici à
l'image et en traçant c'est de droite il
s'est ensuite rendu compte que les deux
trajectoires des tirs se croiser ici en
territoire russe à 8 km dans la
frontière russe ce chercheur a enfin
commander une image satellite de cette
zone où se croisaient les deux
trajectoires et il a trouvé une photo
satellite qui date du 27 février donc la
veille des de la frappe sur car qu'il
est sur cette image satellite la l'on
peut voir les deux trajectoires qui se
croisent en territoire russe une photo
satellite a été commandée sur cette zone
là en russie et le chercheur a repéré un
tir de roquette qui avait lieu la veille
depuis une position de tir us donc on
peut vraisemblablement penser que c'est
un tir qui a été réalisé depuis le
territoire russe qui ait lieu sur cartes
cib le 28 février il y a
oui mais c'est ça et il ya eu plusieurs
plusieurs frappes plusieurs attaques
contre kharkiv ce 28 février csii
amnesty international vient d'en faire
l'écho il y à quelques heures on en
décompte et au moins trois dont 9 civils
qui auraient été tués dont plusieurs
enfants s'étaient internationale qui l'a
annoncé tout récemment merci à thomas
vous arrivez donc à cette conclusion que
l'armée russe a bien utilisé des bombes
à sous-munitions qui sont interdites on
le rappelle pas de conventions
internationales servent que la russie
n'a pas signé merci thomas do de là